next up we're going to California and
I've got Carlos on the line Carlos
what's your question for Anthony hi
there my question is uh if I should say
for four years in buy a house and cash
or if I should buy a house in a year and
stop renting alright that's a nice one
give it a bit give me a little bit of
information about yourself Carlos why
are you out on the baby steps so you
debt-free I'm guessing you're debt-free
and you already have your three to six
months of expenses right yes so we
actually the emergency fund it's going
to be fully funded next month okay so we
kind of wanted to and when I say we I
mean my fiance and I we thought I wanted
to uh start getting ready for it and
seeing you know what's the next move and
how old are you how old are you - I'm
I'm 29
she's 27 okay cool and how much is was
your income a year so I grows around 275
to 325 and she makes around 55 and
obviously we're not counting it cuz when
I'm married yeah we'll be married in
September okay cool great so how much of
a house are you looking to buy in
California cuz I mean I'm from San Diego
so that's not a cheap area to buy ya
know so we're actually looking at a
townhome something around a 600 uh about
650 or so cool I'm out here and like
Chino Hills your Belinda so it's uh and
you feel as if Spencer cooling you
throws it within four years she can pay
cash for that yeah so right now in our
current renting for about $2,300 right
now in an apartment okay and we feel
that we can save around 125 to 150 maybe
a little bit more just depending you
know what kind of year we have yeah you
know what man I actually like the fact
of you if 29 she's 27 so this means by
the time you turn my age 35 you can pay
cash for a home makes its launch if on
the baby steps and loans you're still
investing I don't have a problem with
you being patient and bearing cash but
if you decide to go in to buy it now
with the next year there's nothing wrong
with that but I'm always gonna lend
towards the side of going ahead and
paying cash okay yeah no I'm proud of
you guys
Carlos with where you are you so you
don't want anything else right now no no
we were to actually follow the baby
steps we were I want to say maybe or I
was more like maybe a hundred and sixty
hundred seventy thousand in bed and over
often around eighteen months or so and
yeah while making money yeah what kind
of debt did you have I was young stupid
so I bought myself a super car and well
you know it goes from there and pay that
off with a bid and credit cards and all
the different stuff and uh super car
what kind of car was it and how dr8 yes
sir yeah what happened guys what caused
you to look at that debt and say no more
when I was around 2025 and around that
time and I bought it and then you know
two years passed and then I started
realizing that I know I make all this
money but I'm still kind of living you
know Patriot to paycheck and you know
just not really really making that money
grow and you know being where I should
be and then I decided to get rid of the
the car stopped buying you know stupid
things that you know young person I
guess will be buying and they don't know
how to manage money so I yeah we're
gonna happen and for the last two years
or so something around that uh
been really focused on you know becoming
a millionaire gotcha when are you
planning to get engaged I will already
engaged we are be married September of
this year okay got you and so you guys
are already having conversations about
money even though you're not married yet
right so we did our own baby stuff she
had her own bed very small compared to
mine dough and she paid hers off a long
time ago and when mine took a little bit
longer so I just finished in December
and then now my emergency fund and you
know get all that taken care of so uh we
wanted to make sure we're getting
married with no death well I'm very
proud of you I'm proud of your focus and
and again looking at this being really
intentional and California you know the
West Coast it's really easy to get want
itis yes it's really easy to look at
what someone else has and
and really gets her eye off the ball of
what it is you're doing and what you
guys stand for and so I like your
mindset I like that you've been through
some stuff and had to clean up a mess
but I like that your focus now and
you're very intentional on what it is
you're doing talking about buying a
townhome for the dollar amount you're
talking about and discussing 600 to 650
you totally could save up and pay cash
or if you were to move forward you could
still attack it and pay it off
so either way I like the idea of you
having this thing paid off before you
ever get close to being 33 years old
which gives you an amazing advantage if
you stay focused and so it's about being
intentional and I'm proud of you and I'm
proud of the direction that you're going